less than two weeks to make a decision
no sign of a deal yet I mean where do we
go from here it's really hard how Jeremy
is trying to bring people together and
we are trying to see what Parliament can
agree on I mean the difficulty is is
that it is also last-minute and and the
reason for that is because we have been
trying to tell the Prime Minister for a
couple of years now the sorts of things
that people could agree about but she
just doesn't listen you need more MPs to
compromise don't you you're talking
about trying to find a solution of
course party solution you have a new
voted or abstain done quite a few
different options do you think some of
your colleagues need to do the same I
think that I think that people do need
to compromise of course they do we do
think that what we have been suggesting
is an entirely thought-out we know we've
been talking to Europe about it we've
talked to experts about it what we've
said is that we want to be in a customs
union we want to be close to a single
market we need to have dynamic alliance
of rules and regulations so that you
know we can be we can be outside the
European Union but not very far because
we think that the 52:48 actually spoken
the essential truth which is that yes
you know we do need to leave the
European Union there was a referendum
but we mustn't ignore the 48% and we
need to therefore leave but not go far
so you're talking about the fact you
want to be a customs union when we close
do you just explain to me what it is do
you have an issue with about the
withdrawal agreement that's the Prime
Minister's deal that she keeps put that
she put forward to the house I mean the
problem with the withdrawal agreement is
first of all is that she's she's set her
face so against there being in a customs
union but there is the customs union in
the withdrawal agree mean that's the
backstop well there's the backstop but
the difficulty is with the backstop is
that it only applies to part of the part
of the United Kingdom and not to all of
the United Kingdom ineffectively
unaccustom'd so Watchmen what we said is
that is a backstop doesn't know but what
we need to do is we need to have some I
mean so okay so she puts forward a
suggestion what you're really saying I
knew this morning is she's put forward
this idea that's full of kind of
unicorns and rainbows that doesn't make
any sense and the European Union has
said all right Theresa if you really
insist
we'll agree to that but we want to have
an insurance policy and the insurance
policy is not acceptable what we should
do is ditch this and just go actually
you know what we'll work is to be in a
customs union and to be close to the
single market and that's how we should
have negotiated throughout she should
have listened to Parliament she should
have consulted actually there is some
common sense in Parliament she should
have paid some attention to what we've
been saying so what if it's specifically
about the withdrawal agreement that
Labour won't vote for it's because it's
so uncertain it's essentially saying you
know let's leave and then whoever is
going to be the leader of the Tory Party
yet and goodness only knows who it might
be
if they remain Prime Minister what it is
that they will negotiate and we cannot
trust them we can't trust them and
business needs to be sure about where it
is that we're going and what it is that
we're doing next which is why you know
I've said I do Prime Minister's
Questions I think two and a half years
ago and I made it clear in the House of
Commons then that on our side of the
house we think that we should be in the
customs union no ifs no buts
being a customs union I understand that
you're saying that you don't know that
the shape of the future relationship but
that's the --use fault isn't it because
they laid out right at the beginning
that you need to sort out the divorce
before the future relationship can be
sorted so the divorce is to withdrawal
agreement and that still struggling to
find now if you're looking for fault
what are you the fault is is about it
that you don't so the fault is this
right is that is that we have a
referendum people say they want to leave
there has to be another injection of
democracy after that we can't just say
we're going to leave and then hand it
over to Teresa Mae and let her do
whatever she wants with our country she
ought to have been listening and there
needed to be a democratic input we said
democratic input should be a meaningful
vote in a meaningful vote is something
with meaning it's you know come back
with your suggestions Parliament can
vote on it if we don't like it then you
can go away have a rethink and go back
to Europe and negotiate something with a
with a mandate from the whole of
Parliament but she's been taking them
Mickey you know she should have come
back in October she put it back till
November then December then January you
know and then even with just you know
days to go she's still saying it's my
Deal or No Deal and that is not
meaningful that is not democracy that is
Teresa may just stamping her feet and
saying I want this no one else is
allowed to do
anything else no wonder she's in trouble
I mean it's she's out of control you
know there is no she's not listening to
anyone no one knows what it is that
she's going to do next
I think her judgment has been undermined
and yet and yet you know we don't know
whether she's going to remain prime
minister if we're gonna get somebody
else who that other person is going to
be you know what the future is it is a
mess and as I say all I'm trying to say
to you this morning
is that we have as the opposition been
truly trying to engage in a way which is
which is helpful which is which actually
brings a bit of common sense to the
debate okay so I mean you're talking
about the need for a meaningful vote it
does feel as if kind of Labor's position
it's moving towards what you describes a
meaningful vote what others may describe
as a second referendum I just wanna have
a look at something so no no our
meaningful vote was was come back with
your ideas and then get it through
Parliament and Parliament had to have
the final say but because she wasn't
prepared to do any you know backwards
and forwards with us so we she wasn't
prepared to listen to us saying actually
we need to be at a customs union for her
to go I don't really like customs you
are you sure actually have a discussion
and then between us we could come to
some form of solution er this is what
Jeremy is trying to do now but that's
this is why we're doing it so much at
the last minute is because until now
we've been blocked from that by a prime
minister saying I'm in charge and it's
my way or the highway so are you going
to call a confidence motion in the Prime
Minister that we shall see I mean
obviously it does look like time may
come where we will need to call another
confidence I mean it's gonna be this
week the thing I've got much time I know
in my eggs until we leave it's a
collective decision and not one that I
can make on your program on fright okay
okay I collect a decision as in around
the shadow cabinet table it's a yeah
it's done by the leadership in
consultation with senior members okay
and now we might be in election
territory clearly what would Labour's
position be going into that election
would it be that we want to leave with a
deal or would it be actually we want to
put the whole thing back to other people
with us with a second referendum and the
principle is and further you know some
of the half a million people who belong
to the Labour Party who
watching this program this morning the
prints they know that the principle is
that they have a say and what our
manifesto is it isn't kind of you know
as it was with Teresa Mays last
manifesto it isn't a couple of people in
the backroom election I mean that
collection last time you go shooting
labor but then in negotiating breaks it
for years now what surely we should know
what Labor's position would be going
into well I can tell you what Labor's
position is now and I can tell you what
I would think will be in the manifesto
but I can't be sure because it is it is
it's not for me to decide it is for the
membership desire we have a pot we have
it believe that you you or not so what
we would need to do is is I mean we have
to abide by the results of the
referendum and so the problem is at the
moment we are in a complete deadlock so
the question will be how do we break the
deadlock do we break the deadlock by way
of of being able to to agree something
in Parliament you know if we can't agree
something in Parliament then what do we
do
do we have a general election or do we
have a popular vote and these things
need to be sort up because we can't be
left it would really that you are not
under a Labour government I think that
we're likely to leave the EU but I think
that it is something that we need to
agree ourselves in and I think there is
a strong argument for that asking the
people to have the final say on this
particularly since everything is so
controversial at this stage okay and we
can have a look I'm your colleague Barry
Gardner said this week and the Labour
Party is not a remain party now where is
he right we're an internationalist we're
Europeans I think that it's quite
difficult for us to to leave the
European Union most of us campaign to
remain I think in our hearts we want to
remain but the difficulty is is that we
have to square that with democracy we're
Democrats above everything else and if
the people want us to leave then we have
to leave and it's been our job to try to
make sure that we leave in terms that
cause the least amount of damage to jobs
into the economy so in your heart do you
want to stay
Oh in my heart I want to stay I think
it's in Britain's interest to remain in
the European Union without a doubt but
but actually what tops everything else
to me is democracy and if the people
want us to leave then as I say it's my
job as a public servant to try to do as
untold and to try to do it in a way
which doesn't harm us
if public opinion has changed if the
public wants to remain them that's
obviously a challenge for all of us and
we need to think again about that or if
we end up in a deadlock or we end up in
a situation where we may be you know
going for no deal then I think that it's
right for us to go to the people and to
say you know do you want to have for
example two resumes deal or two remain
and in those circumstances I would
obviously be campaigning
Tremayne I went down to the brexit March
on Friday where lots of leave voters
were you know just saying how fast rate
to pay water by the fact we weren't
leaving on Friday as the prime minister
had promised it and I spoke to one guard
there who was 17 years old she was
standing underneath a suffragette flag
and what she said could have really
stayed with me so I just want to put to
you what she said if that's okay she
talked about the suffragettes they
fought for my right to vote and then I'm
here to fight for that vote to be
counted if we don't leave the European
Union democracy is just gone I mean
never feels like there is going to be a
huge crisis of faith in democracy if
there's another referendum if we stay in
the EU I mean this is something that we
are wrestling with I mean I understand
that I mean the first point I don't
wanna make a cheat point but she
wouldn't be able to vote you know I mean
she'd be able to vote if I got my way or
if labor got our way 16 year-olds will
be able to vote and of course there is
an argument that if 16 and 17 year-olds
were able to vote then yeah there would
be a much larger proportion of the
population wanting to remain them
although who's not hurt that girl but
yes I mean I think I think the whole
point has been is that we have a
referendum you know we've got a
particular result I personally don't
really understand why 70 percent of the
population at this moment don't want to
remain in the European Union but they
don't I personally think that the reason
for that is because we have not had the
sort of debate that we need to have I
think that it's been completely
disrespectful on both sides of people
just shouting at each other as opposed
to just concentrating on the issues and
looking at them honestly and saying
really is this helping our country are
we getting all the things that were
promised during the referendum by the
levers or are we having to compromise so
much that if we were to stand back and
look at it is it really in our interest
leave and I wish that we could have a
debate along those lines but we don't
seem to have and people have got dug in
and any given that people have got
touchy and then given that public
opinion has not changed in such a major
way I can still see the argument for us
needing to leave okay if the deadline is
fast approaching would you be
comfortable with a longer extension
taking part in the European elections if
it meant leaving with it I do we have to
it's going to be very I mean I in
practice I can't see how we can we can
get everything organized in a couple of
weeks and we again we just need a bit of
honesty and dejected into this so I
think that we will need to extend I
don't personally think that we need to
be involved in the European elections I
think that there is a side protocol that
can be negotiated are you preparing for
European elections well yes obviously we
have to make preparations for it because
if that happens then it happens and we
need to make sure that we we stand
candidates but we think that there's
another way through this and we think
that if we need to have longer a longer
period of time than currently is on
offer then it can be done I mean the
process is difficult but where politics
says yes we should do it then actually
you can find a way through this process
okay now while we've got you on just
keen to ask one story that isn't brexit
related and that is the government's
decision to try and potentially increase
the number of stop and search that the
police are using to try and combat knife
crime forty-eight people stabbed to
death this year alone it's not something
that you Arkham I think that we need to
do everything that we can in order to
protect our youngsters I have lost far
too many constituents and to life crime
I I write letters to grieving mothers
and go around and see them and it's the
worst part of my job I've had teenagers
in my borough brought up I i have
worried about them and we have had times
in his linton where everyone has been
very scared and when good kids who
wouldn't normally carry knives for
heaven's sake have started carrying them
because they wanted to defend themselves
and they and we found knives that are
hidden in the parks you know there are
times when anxiety spikes to such
Stanton there's a level of hysteria it
needs to be broken and in those
circumstances the police I think do need
to have the power to essentially stop
everybody and so long as it is done in a
way which is respectful and where where
it's explained to people how and why
it's being done then you know it's
protecting all of us I mean one of the
times when it was done in my borough
my daughter was stopped she's a very
prickly and difficult individual at
times and I'm surprised she wasn't
arrested on the spot but but you know I
mean they were stopping everybody and
they were being very careful about how
they were doing it and how did she feel
was she she was outraged what she was
outraged and she came home and I
explained to her you know why it was
being done and and then it was there to
protect everybody and to make sure that
everybody was was as safe as they can be
now this is not a solution in itself and
of course if it is not done properly it
just it can make matters worse and it
can make particular groups feel like
they are marginalized and picked on and
seen as criminals as they walk down the
street when you know the only thing you
know I mean it's just it's not it's it's
not done fairly so it needs to be done
fairly it needs to be done respectfully
and in moments of crisis I can see the
reason for needing to increase the
police's powers of stop and search okay
emily Thorne brain thank you very much